Given a plaintext input, the encryption
algorithm performs transformation to
produce the corresponding ciphertext.
The decryption algorithm
reverses the encryption process.
That is,
it takes as input the ciphertext and
produces the original plaintext.
Instead of using a single key,
as in the symmetric encryption here,
asymmetric encryption
use a pair of keys.
One is used for encryption and
the other is used for decryption.
The two keys are paired
mathematically together.
That is, if you use a key for
encryption,
only the corresponding paired
key can decrypt a message.
Let's look at the essential
steps in asymmetric encryption.
First, each user generates
a pair of keys that are paired
together mathematically.
One is the private key,
the other is the public key.
The public key can be published,
for example, on a user's website or
on a public repository.
The purpose is for
everybody to know your public key, but
a companion private key has
to be kept as a secret.
That is, only the user should
know his or her own private key.
Since public keys are meant
to be known by others,
we can imagine that in practice, a user
such as Bob would have a collection of
public keys of his friends.
For example, in this case, Bob has the
public keys of Alice, Ted, Mike and Joy.
Now suppose Bob wants to send
a private message to Alice.
Bob will use Alice's public key,
which is in his collection to encrypt
a plaintext using a asymmetric
encryption algorithm such as RSA and
then transmit the ciphertext to Alice.
It is mathematically guaranteed
that only Alice can decrypt this
ciphertext properly into plaintext,
because only Alice has the corresponding
companion private key.
That is, if a public key is used to
encrypt a plaintext into the ciphertext,
only the companion
corresponding public key can
decrypt the ciphertext
properly into the plaintext.
Therefore, in this case,
only Alice can see the plaintext.